Salut à tous c’est Pêcheur de trésors
Aujourd'hui, on est encore en compagnie
de Wim, de Danny, de Jade
et de Rasta et Sidney qui sont là.
Et là bas ?
Et aujourd'hui,
on a quelque chose de spécial aussi.
Parce que Wim nous emmené un aimant, un nouvel aimant
Un aimant particulier puisque c’est un aimant d'éolienne
et on le test tout de suite
Quentin a quelque chose avec
Oh
Ne le colle pas à la barrière
Parce qu'il est costaud celui là.
Regardez comme il est, c’est un rectangle
Et il est puissant
ça marche bien,
C’est vraiment différent du barbarian
Il n’attire pas sur 360°
ça accroche vraiment par faces
Et pas en haut je crois
Sympa ton nouveau tatoo.
Merci
Jade me l’a fait
Bon cadeau, merci !
Avec plaisir
C’est Wim qui a offert cet aimant surpuissant
Allez le petit lancer d’aimant d’éolienne
ça vole bien
ça doit bien entrer dans la vase
Intéressant pour les coins comme ici, sûrement déjà prospectés
On commence, voyons ce qu’on trouve
Premier lancer de Wim
il a déjà la première trouvaille
une bobine de cuivre
et un bout de tube, super
Super, ça commence bien
Une pièce de monnaie, ok
0,01€,
J’ai quelque chose
Oula
D’accord
On va vous montrer la taille du truc.
C’est une très, très grande barre
Il va vous montrer la taille du truc.
C’est une très grande perche
j’ai quelque chose,
qu'est ce que c'est ?
Ah d'accord.
Notre petite lumière de scooter.
peut-être que le scooter aussi
est à l'intérieur.
On va essayer de
le trouver. Désolé, un peu de vent.
Du coup,
cette vidéo sera surtout en français,
Mais aussi avec de l’anglais (sous-titré)
Un panneau d'escalier.
C’est la même ?
Une tirelire
Regardons ce qu’il y a dedans
Rien du tout
Seulement des moules
Ca reste une trouvaille cool
Intéressante
Encore une tirelire en forme de billet.
On a trouvé la même
il y a quelques jours ensemble.
C'est rigolo.
Vous êtes peut-être beaucoup a avoir ce genre de tirelires, dîtes nous le en commentaires
Si si vous l'avez et essayez de ne pas
vous la faire piquer comme eux.
Comme sûrement ces personnes.
Quentin
pêche encore avec un aimant d'éolienne.
Il est en train de tester ça
Ma première trouvaille de la journée
avec le nouvel aimant
Oh, une échelle,
OK, on a quelque chose.
Un gros pot d'échappement
Tu es déjà fatigué ?
vieu pots d'échappement
Ah oui.
ça va lâcher
Avec un aimant.
Oui il faut un autre aimant
Là
aie aie aie
ça va lâcher
Le pire scénario
c’était sur
Bien joué on va essayer de le retrouver
Ok.
On décale vers la droite
pour être sûr de ne pas le perdre
On a un sac
On a un sac, accroché à un siège
encore.
Ouais
Si on peut remonter carrément sur la terre
comme ça on ne les perds pas
OK, bien.
L'odeur.
On t’attends
Je t’aide un peu en même temps
C’est bon
OK, alors ça c'est mieux.
C'est de la mousse jaune à l’intérieur.
En attendant, on va ouvrir le sac
C'est bon. Merci.
Ouverture du sac
Il y a une poche
Non il est vide
Mais Jade a gagné un nouveau sac
Génial
Il est beau, t’es contente ?
Je ne le garde pas
Il est super joli tu devrais...
Je vais essayer par en dessous
c'est une belle télé
Remplie de vase.
Totalement remplie de vase.
Un vrai.
Super.
ça n'a aucun sens.
C’est pour ça qu’on pêche ici
On peut trouver ça ici.
Regardez, il a tout pris sur ses jambes
et il s'en fiche.
En même temps, il y a quelques temps,
il était dans les cours d'eau
en train de plonger la tête dedans.
Donc c'est pas un peu de boue
dans les pieds qui va le gener
Désolé pour le vent
Il fonctionne bien ton aimant
Oui ça va
une sorte de...
Pédalier. Pédalier.
Ah non un morceau de treuil
ou de mobylette
Oui, c'est bien joué
C’est une lame de sécateur
Jade remonte un caddie
toute seule
bravo !
on va pouvoir mettre toutes
nos découvertes à l'intérieur.
Bien joué, bien joué
Viens m’aider Baptiste
bien joué
c’est lourd
On va le monter
comme ça,
on met les découvertes dedans, il est sympa.
Bien joué.
Oui Jade a encore quelque chose.
Pour l'instant,
c'est elle qui fait le plus de trouvaille
avec le petit aimant Terror
Un sapin de Noël, non ?
Ah oui, ok.
Sympa.
Oh, c'est lourd.
Ah une échelle.
Y a que des échelles
C'est l'ancien échelle qui était là bas
J'ai un gros truc bien lourd.
J'ai besoin d’aide Bapt
C’est massif
Quentin est toujours là
bas, il galère sur un truc
Je vais aller l'aider.
J'arrive, c'est presque faisable seul.
Peut-être un scooter
Ouais peut être.
Ça paraît plus massif
et un peu moins lourd.
On un rail ?
pour être massif, c'est massif.
Regarde comme l’aimant s’est accroché
la preuve que ça fonctionne bien
il est puissant
Il est juste accroché su son angle c’est incroyable
Bon et d'ailleurs regardez,
j'ai ressenti le polo et l’ancien logo
Parce que t’as perdu tes t-shirts
Surtout parce qu'on pêche tellement
qu'ils sont tous sales.
Et ça, c'était quand on avait
dans les 4000 ou 5000 abonnés
peut être 10000 au maximum.
C'est des polos Norauto
Donc, si vous vous rappelez de ça,
on se moquait de nous
parce qu'on avait des
polos Norauto ou Carglass.
Moi, j'ai quelque chose
je l’ai perdu
attends
Un aimant.
Il était juste là
C'est vers la montée qu'il se bloque,
on dirait.
J'ai pas compris pourquoi en plus,
parce qu'il avait l'air bien aimanté
Il y a encore plein de choses.
C’est fou
En plus c’est bien aimanté ce type d’objets
J'avoue
On va voir ce que j'ai.
OK protoxyde d'azote.
Comme quoi, même dans les coins paumés,
même ici, on en trouve
un bag, un sac
quelque chose à l’intérieur ?
OK, j'ai une ceinture de sécurité
j'ai quelque chose
juste en bas de la pente.
On va voir ce qu'ils ont jeté ici ?
Une trottinette.
Parfait,
parfait, parfait. Parfait.
Je pensais pas en trouver ici,
mais comme quoi
on peut vraiment en trouver de partout.
Les trottinettes, c'est vraiment l'objet
qu'on trouve le plus en ce moment.
OK, quelque chose
L’autre ceinture de sécurité.
Voilà.
Parfait.
Wim a quelque chose de l'autre
côté du pont,
on va essayer de le filmer par là
un morceau très fin de carrosserie de voiture
Ils ont sorti un bout de carrosserie
Moi, j'ai peut être enfin récupéré
un objet qui faisait que retomber là bas.
On va voir.
Oh oui, un panneau
et il n'est pas aimanté.
C'est de l'alu.
Oh, il a eu un accident de voiture
lui aussi.
Pause repas
avec les deux animaux à quatre pattes.
Un peu intéressés, hein ?
Et moi, j'ai peut être quelque chose.
Pendant ce temps,
on va voir si ça va être la trouvaille
qui va me permettre
de prendre ma pause repas.
J'ai pas l'impression.
Que. C'est un truc de chariot,
peut être qu'il y a 1 euro à l'intérieur.
On espère tous
Même pas
Ils vont lui parler en français
On l’a bien eu !
J’ai attrapé
Wim a quelque chose
le deuxième siège
Ça, c'était sur.
OK, je l'ai
C’est juste l’assise ça va avec
ok parfait
Merci beaucoup. De rien, c’est un très bon grappin
Ça vient
Oh oh non, un pot d'échappement.
OK, ok, oui,
aimant puissant
un peti moteur
Pas mal pour le ferrailleur.
Téléphone allemand,
Telefunken
Ce téléphone bas de gamme appartenait surement a un dealer
Ils les jettent
après s'en être servi quelques jours,
c'est toujours intéressant.
C'est bon signe, ça montre
Il y a quand même
des délinquants qui passent par là,
même si c'est un coin un peu paumé
j'ai quelque chose de jaune Quentin
Tu vois ce que c'est ? Non,
c'est un cutter, mais.
Sans lame
J’ai une bouteille de gaz hilarant ! Rien d’autre
C'est une bouteille de gaz hilarant
avec les protoxyde d'azote.
Ouais, c'est la deuxième qu’on trouve ici
On va voir.
Il reste pas grand chose sur ce spot,
même s'il y a des morceaux qui attrapent.
Ils n’accrochent pas bien, c'est galère.
Moi j'ai fait dix aimants vides là
donc j'en ai marre.
On va changer de pont,
je vais toujours tester cet aimant
Donc c'est parti pour faire un deuxième
spot.
On a pas mal de ponts en tête
et voilà on en même temps.
On emmène encore Wim et Danny avec nous,
n'hésitez pas à regarder la chaîne de Wim
qui est en description de la vidéo
qui sort du lourd
à Bruxelles, Molenbeek et Anderlecht.
Si je prononce bien cette fois
dîtes moi
les Belges en commentaires. C’est pas Molenbeek ?
Ne me criez pas dessus
J’aurais dis Molenbeek
Tu dis Molenbek ou Molenbeek ?
Ouais, ben oui, ils le disaient à la télé
qu'il y avait les djihadistes.
Mais non, il disait que l'accent français
justement, et alors ? Justement
Dites nous en commentaire.
Les belges
Et comme d'habitude
récupèrent toute la ferraille
Elle sera vendue chez le ferrailleur au poids
Rien.
Et Dany a une chaise.
Oh bien joué.
Quentin tu as un truc ?
J'ai quelque chose oh non pas ici....
Ah non, c'est pas du protoxyde d'azote
pour une fois, c'est une arme
Un pistolet
Pistol.
Avec un pistolet
Ce n’est pas le style de pistolet que l’on cherche
À ce genre de chose.
C’est un bon début
J'ai quelque chose. Oh,
un arbre et un boitier étrange
On va regarder ce que c'est.
Un disque dur peut être
l’arbre est retourné à l’eau
C’est une cassette de caméra pour la lire dans un magnétoscope
ouais on va regarder
et je crois qu'on peut lire quel film c’est
cassette
video
Vidéo casette
on l’ouvre
Ah non c’est vide
C’est un adaptateur
Tu mets la eptite cassette de camescope dedans
OK ok,
ok je vois
C’est VHS
C’est spécial
Adapteur
Mais belle découverte
un camescope.
Ouais
un camescope, mais il est retombé.
Il allait avec l’adaptateur surement
Un truc lourd.
ça bouge
On est sur le même. he crois que oui
Non ?
Moi je veux mon camescope
ça vient d’une voiture ça
C’est le toit de la voiture.
On le sort comme ça
on pourra sortir le camescope après.
Un c'est super lourd ou encore.
Là ça va
Ne lâchez pas
Il tient juste avec les câbles.
Caca
Je suis déjà fatigué
sacré morceau de voiture, on va essayer de continuer
Je vais continuer à lancer par là.
Il y avait plein d'objets
Y en a plein qui viennent
pas mais ils vont finir par venir
Là, j'ai eu quelque chose.
Enfin,
j'ai eu un petit pistolet à peinture mais a part ça
oh pied de biche.
Un grand pied de biche
Bon travail
C’est un beau modèle
ok.
Il faut le garder
Oui bien sur
OK. Merci.
OK, donc c'est un pied de biche.
il a dit qu'il avait des choses dedans.
C'est des outils ou tous
incroyable
On est abonné aux sacs d’outils
cool.
Oh, une montre Apple Watch !
Apple ?
cool
Made in China
Oh Samsung !
merci je suis content
pas besoin de gaz hilarant
Moi aussi, toujours heureux
merci Jade
Je suis content
Et Rasta qu’est-ce qu’il en pense ?
Il a l’air content
C’est lourd ?
Content rasta.
ok des tournevis abimés
2022, ce n’est pas vieux il y a les dates dessus
un antivol avec la clef
elle date de 2022 la batterie
Rien de bien.
Une boucle d’oreille
Elle est belle et n’est pas aimantée
Je te l’offre ?
Mais grave elle est trop belle
Il y a un diamant dessus
Peut-être de l’argent derrière
Il faut toujours vérifier
Oui on regarde toujours derrière
C’est un galaxy S4 je crois, pas tout jeune
Là aussi tu devrais avoir la date de fabrication
2020, c'est le début du code.
Voilà. OK.
bien
il est tout neuf.
Je pense que ça peut marcher de nouveau
Il faudrait les envoyer a notre contact
D'ailleurs, on a déjà envoyé des
des outils en réparation
et il avait réussi à refaire marcher une.
Une boucle d’oreille
ah non une bague
C’est de l'argent
Ça veut dire que c'est de l'argent,
mais qu'il a été.
doré, super.
C’est super
Bravo Baptiste !
Merci
Offre la à ta chérie ? (Il n’en a pas manifestez vous en commentaires)
Dîtes nous en commentaires à qui vous voulez que je l'offre du coup...
A ta belle soeur préférée
T’as déjà eue la boucle d'oreille !
Ah oui c’est vrai
Fallait attendre de voir ce qu’il y avait de mieux avant de demander
Tu lui offre la montre connectée aussi ?
C’est incroyable.
Vous avez vu, on trouve un sac d'outils
et à l'intérieur,
une boucle d'oreille en argent.
Et cette magnifique bague
qui est aussi en argent
et plaqué or avec des brillants
donc peut être des petits diamants aussi.
On sait jamais.
Oh oui, un bijoux
c'est peut être même pas aimanté.
En plus, c'est coincé dans le truc.
encore un bijou
Regarde on va voir s'il est aimanté
Pas ça.
D'une boucle d'oreille.
C’était aussi dans le sac sûrement
oui surement
cool
Bien joué la plaque d’immatriculation
Il faut la rechercher sur le registre
Elle est très ancienne
C'est trop vieux. Ouais
Les noirs sont les plus anciennes
Elle est en acier, habituellement elles sont en aluminium
Elle a entre 50 et 80 ans
C’est un souvenir
Un souvenir de la France bien sûr